we are celebrating hispanic heritage
month
and i don't know about you but i do love
experiencing and appreciating cultures
through food
and we are so lucky to have this
distinguished chef
to come here and cook with us today he
is passionate about preserving his
family's legacy
i've been reading all about it in his
book he wants to have the diversity in
the kitchen
honor his family please welcome the
author of where i come from
life lessons from a latino chef aaron
sanchez i i can't believe i'm
i'm kind of trippin man i have been
watching you
on tv for so long and i
love chefs versus city and i love your
book
well thank you so much drew and by the
way i'm a huge fan of yours
i'm so happy for all your success and
yeah it's hispanic heritage month it's
about
uh remembering and honoring all the
accomplishments that latinos and
hispanics have made
all over the world so what better way to
celebrate that than with food right
but let's start with this recipe what do
you think drew i'm very excited to learn
anything from you arone awesome you are
such a sweetheart um let's go ahead and
start with the pico de gallo now again
this is all about the freshness of the
tomatoes so we're going to add
everything into a bowl right so we have
some chopped tomato
no big deal okay so tomato
cilantro no particular order because
it's all going to go in there
we have half of the white onion that's
chopped okay
then we have some jalapeno now this is
to
to gusto right to your liking so if you
like a little spicier put more jalapeno
it's up to you
i like it a little bit you do great oh
yeah i like that super spicy
and a little bit and a little bit of
scallion
and then just to finish some lime juice
okay
and let this kind of sit do its thing
and then as that's going i want you to
have your pan
your pan nice and hot okay drew
and then put some salt in there a little
bit of pepper
no biggie yep it looks beautiful by the
way i can see it
oh well okay that's it so in this pan
i've rendered some bacon
and this is optional if you want to keep
it a hundred percent uh vegetarian you
can just omit the bacon
okay so i've reserved some of that bacon
grease
and then a little bit of olive oil okay
okay what we're going to go ahead and do
is throw in our harmony
that's been rinsed okay now this is a
canned product which is great
it's a perfect side dish for anything
like coming up for a holiday or
thanksgiving you can serve this on the
side and it's great
uh we get all excited when we're gonna
start with a little bit
exactly so put some onion in there as
well we're going to go ahead and put
the harmony uh-huh okay let it do its
thing
then we're going to add some garlic
okay now drew i have some garlic some
mexican oregano okay it's dried
and then you're going to put some fresh
oregano in there as well okay
so we're sauteing the hominy and then
now we're going to add that pico de
gallo
oh inside okay group right into the hot
you can see that
yeah and then we're gonna give it a
little saute
okay let all those flavors meld and come
together
and then i like to put a little pad of
butter right at the end
a little pad of butter okay
there you go and then guess what drew
we're gonna go to the plate
it's time to play okay
i don't even okay around you so
[Applause]
this pan was made for the incredible
hulk and the last time i checked
lou ferrigno was out to lunch so
um basically my homies don't worry just
use a spoon
i don't know oh well i guess darn it i
had a ladle
son of a yeah now you can um
sprinkle with some of that bacon if you
want just on top to give it a little bit
more of that
texture and that little salty and crispy
bits maybe a little bit more cilantro
um okay ready ready for a big shot here
we go
yeah baby you are the beauty shop
you are i can't believe i'm actually
getting to cook with you you have no
idea
how much i've appreciated you and how
much i've learned and
i know that you have a very important
foundation also
um that i want to mention yes it's
incredible
yeah thank you for mentioning it's the i
don't such a scholarship fund and when i
started cooking 25 years ago i thought
there was a huge disparity
between latinos and there are some of my
kids right there
they're just i couldn't be prouder of
them they have
come from very humble roots and they're
chasing their dreams to be chefs
so our kids uh go to culinary school
in new york city at the best culinary
school available they go through a
11-month program
and then they're they're they're
mentored and they're encouraged to do
internships with different chefs
that's one of the things i'm most proud
of right now so well i'm sure you use
your platform to keep us
informed of their journey and i can't
wait
to see anyone under your tutelage or
wing because
you have the best taste yes i said it
pun intended i'm trying this speaking of
taste
i love it good you're better oh isn't
that delicious oh my gosh
thank you so much and we're going to
talk about your foundation on our
website so go to the
drewberrymoreshow.com
for this full recipe and how to support
the oron sanchez scholarship foundation
thank you aron thank you it's a
privilege to finally meet you in person
you